[Music]
Hello to our friends and members of the
SumTV family. This is I'd like to know,
a Bible question and answer program here
on Sum TV and one of our favorite
pastimes or avocations uh because we
love studying the word of God and we do
sincerely love answering your questions
from the word of God. My name is CA
Murray. I'm in the company of Pastor
Steven Boore, who is our founder and
president. Pastor, always good to have
you on set.
>> I love to be in this program.
>> And Pastor David Salazar, who is the
general manager of our Latino channel,
doing a fine job. David, always good to
have you here.
>> Thank you, pastor. A privilege for me to
be with you and Pastor Boore.
>> And it is always good to take your
questions. As we said, should you want
to get in on the fun, please write to
us, email us at tvsumtv.org.
You see it there uh lower thirds on your
screen. TV tvsum summ as in marytv.org.
And we will get to your question, we
promise. And we'll answer from the word
of God. We make you that promise and
pledge. Also, my dear pastor and friend,
would you lead us out in prayer?
>> Let's pray.
Father in heaven, what an awesome
privilege it is to call you father,
the ideal perfect father. We come before
you today with humility of heart,
realizing that we are but dust. We know
so little. And therefore, as we begin
this program, we ask that you will be
with us through the Holy Spirit and you
will give us your wisdom that we might
be able to answer these questions in
harmony with your word and our answers
might be a blessing to those who watch
this program.
We crave and plea for your presence as
we begin to answer these questions. And
we know that you have answered because
we ask it in the precious name of Jesus.
Amen.
>> Amen. And amen.
>> Amen.
>> All right. This one comes from Prince F.
Again, no location, but we thank you,
Prince, for your question. Hi, SUM
teams.
I have been battling trying to figure
out how to show from scripture alone
that the judgment began in 1844
with reference to Daniel 8:14 after the
2300 day prophecy ends or how the
cleansing of the sanctuary interpret
interprets to be uh judgment. I can
imagine also that the judgment would be
linked to Daniel 7:26 and Revelation
14:7.
I'm doing studies with non-adventists
who want to be confident
uh in showing this particular fact of
reality from the Bible. I am I am
principled in using scripture to prove
scripture to prove scripture to prove
scripture to prove scripture. So, he
wants to prove it from scripture.
>> Uh, which is okay because that's how
William Miller did it. He didn't have
spirit of prophecy.
>> Please assist. I'm desirous in knowing
how to do this awesome work for God so
no one can honestly refute what I am
making up uh
>> that I am making up
>> that I am making up my own ideas or
being denominationally
biased. I wish to understand like
Daniel, I am not I but I
am not understanding by books alone.
The one thing I can say as far as
methodology,
you're dealing with scripture, you're
dealing with judgment, you're dealing
with sanctuary. You've got your Daniel
8:14, which gives you your 2300 days. If
you want to understand where that's
coming from, the first thing you need to
do is go back in the Bible and
understand the sanctuary and the
sanctuary system.
>> That gives you a foundation, a floor, a
rubric on which you can build all of
your other understandings. Maybe we
ought to read Daniel 7:26 and Revelation
14:10 because they they do deal with
judgment, but it all stems from the
sanctuary system because that's your
parallel. That's your your uh the thing
that you want to build this this
foundation on. So, pastor, you have uh
>> I have Daniel 7 verse 26.
>> Okay.
>> Daniel 7 verse 26 reads like this. But
the court shall be seated. This is the
heavenly court by the way. And they
shall take away his dominion. In other
words, the dominion of the little horn
>> to consume and destroy it forever.
Mhm. And Revelation 14:7,
it reads, "Sing with a loud voice, fear
God and give glory to him, for the hour
of his judgment has come, and worship
him who ha who made heaven and earth,
the sea, and the springs of water."
>> Okay. Uh let me just make a few remarks.
In the question
he suggests that the judgment needs to
be linked with Daniel 7 verse 26.
Uh I would go beyond what he mentions in
his question. The seventh adventist
church has a method of interpreting
prophecy which is known as historicism.
Mhm.
>> It's the idea that prophecy begins to
chain prophecies begin to be fulfilled
in the days when the prophet wrote, when
the prophet was alive and then you have
a sequence of events leading up to the
final judgment and the setting up of
Christ's everlasting kingdom. In other
words, it shows you the flow from
Babylon all the way to the eternal
kingdom.
>> Mhm.
>> In sequence,
>> correct? without interruption.
>> Now in Daniel 7, we read verse 26, but
we really have to look at the beginning
of the chapter
>> precisely
>> because you have a lion which represents
Babylon. Then you have a bear which is
Meo Persia. Then you have a leopard
which is Greece. Then you have a
nondescript beast with 10 horns which
represents the Roman Empire which was
divided into 10 kingdoms. And then you
have a little horn who rules until the
year 1798,
>> right?
>> And then after 1798, you have this
judgment scene. So the judgment does not
take place until after 1798
>> when you read Daniel 7.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, Daniel 7 doesn't give you the exact
date for the beginning of the judgment.
So you're left with the question, okay,
so the judgment begins after the little
horn loses its power in 1798.
So the big question is
what date does the judgment begin?
For that you have to go to Daniel
chapter 8
>> where you have Meo Persia first, then
you have Greece, then you have the
division of Greece.
>> Yeah. Then you have the little horn and
then you have a reference to the 2300
day prophecy.
>> Right?
>> Now for this you have to for the 2300
2300 day prophecy you have to go to
Daniel 9 because Daniel 9 gives you the
starting point for the 70 weeks which is
the first part of the 2300 days.
>> Correct?
>> So see you're you're doing detective
work here. You're comparing scripture
with scripture. You're looking at the
structure. You're looking at the terms
etc. Cleansing of the sanctuary refers
to refers to the judgment. It yam kipur
right
>> and so then you take and you put all the
pieces together and Daniel 8 of course
gives you the date unto 2,300 days the
sanctur shall be cleansed. Now that
begins with a decree to restore and
build Jerusalem which is 457. That's
well established in history. So you have
the first 70 weeks which takes you to
the year 34 the stoning of Steven and
then you have 1810 years left of the
2300 days because the 70 weeks are cut
off from the 2300 days.
>> Correct?
>> And so that takes you to 1844.
>> Now the big question is when in 1844
that gives us a year. Well, you have to
go to the feast of um the feast of the
day of atonement, right?
>> In Leviticus 23,
>> it gives you the day and the month.
>> So then you look for the day and month
equivalent in um 1844
and it gives you October 20 to 1844. Now
this is only a bird's eye view. It might
be might be too much to grasp at this
moment.
How many times have I quoted Ellen White
in the last few words that I've spoken?
>> None.
>> None. Because it can be proven from
scripture that
October 22, 1844 was the beginning of
the heavenly judgment that is described
in Daniel 7 and is described in Daniel 8
as the cleansing of the sanctuary.
>> Yes. So, um, I would recommend a book
written by Clifford Goldstein,
1844,
>> made simple.
>> It's a It's a
almost like a kindergarten type book,
not because it's not profound, but
because a kindergartener can understand
>> the process.
>> And so, I think that uh book is still in
print. It's a small book. It's only I
don't think it's more than 60 or 70
pages,
>> right?
>> But it's profound.
>> It is.
>> So I don't know what else u I I've
spoken enough.
>> No pastor, thank you. I think that you
know adding to what you're saying is
that as you have actually really have
display the concept of how we are to
build and understand and get to this un
to this prophecy and and and explain
what the judgment is. uh you have to and
I I will ask brother Prince to
understand that he has to uh set the
basis the the the foundation correctly
start with Daniel 2, Daniel 7, Daniel 8,
Daniel 9. You have to build upon these
things. You can't just go into the
judgment without having built a base, a
foundation. and and if you are not uh
he's saying he has a hard time sometimes
understanding or or from the books of
the Bible alone uh I think that he needs
to make sure that he takes that method
of going from the foundation from the
basics make sure that he understands
that clearly he can explain that and
then build from there and one last thing
that he mentions that he wants to make
sure that nobody can refute him I think
that's not the intention or the concept
we need to have there's going to be
plenty of people who will not want to
accept the truth no matter how much you
present to them. So you can't expect
people to just say, "Oh, I see what
you're saying. You know, I'm going to
take it as as as as gospel what you're
telling me." You can't and you know, the
the Holy Spirit is the one that actually
>> convicts people of the truth. And some
individuals, the enemy knows and and
uses them. They are going to be, you
know, trying to destroy what you're
saying. So you have to understand that
you have to approach this with a concept
of I am going to have the Holy Spirit
impress and help me to share the truth
and let the Holy Spirit do the work of
convicting people of the truth. And it's
not upon you to to try to be, you know,
undisputable if I could say that. Uh
because there's going to be always
individuals who will discredit and
they're going to go to their pastor and
the pastor are going to say something to
them. And a lot of times that happens
and some people really don't want to
hear the truth no matter how much you
preach said preach them and show them
clear in the Bible.
>> One of the problems that I see in the
world today
is that people want everything
easy
without having to do any research,
>> right?
>> Without having to tax their mind
>> to find relationships in scripture,
>> right? You know, it's manifested by by
these mega preachers.
>> Yeah.
>> Who rarely refer to a Bible verse and
they just want to make people feel good.
But they don't teach people to study.
They don't take teach people to reason,
to struggle with scripture because, you
know, not everything in scripture is
easy to understand.
>> Very true. Right?
>> The apostle Paul wrote some particularly
difficult things to understand according
to his colleague Peter. So, you have to
struggle with the text. You have to
study. You have to do research. You have
to investigate. Um, but we live in a
world where people want immediate
gratification. Yeah.
>> I mean, I want it and I want it now
without any effort.
>> Right.
>> And, uh, there's no way you're going to
understand the depths of the Bible if
you have that attitude. You have to
dedicate yourself to reason. You have to
dedicate yourself to research, to asking
questions of the text and so on. And
most people are not willing to uh, spend
the time uh, in order to do that.
>> Yeah. You will never find a time when
there is no doubt. Ellen White says in
steps to Christ, the reason most people
doubt, well, she says there there there
are genuine
people who have genuine doubts as they
move through their Christian experience.
>> But she says ultimately the reason most
people have doubts is because they don't
want to do,
>> right?
>> And your your lack of willingness to do
occasions your doubts. Yeah. So to think
that you're ever going to run into a a
situation where nobody will refute you
uh is never going to happen because
different minds, different hearts,
different different things.
>> It's all about judgment. Uh Daniel 7:26
is actually the the anticclimactical end
to I mean the the business end of Daniel
7 is up front, right?
>> Uh uh 26 is just what happens because of
what happens up front. And of course
Daniel 74, Daniel 14:7,
>> it's judgment. It's all about judgment.
God has got to deal with the sin
problem.
>> Um, if you look at the the the the
ancient sanctuary system, at the end of
the day, if you weren't part of the
system, you were cut off.
>> So, judgment was was rendered. Judgment
was made, right?
>> And at the end of of this world,
>> if you're not in, you're out. It's it's
all about judgment. God will give you
what you've worked for. If you work for
heaven, you get it. If you work against
heaven, well, you get that, too.
>> So, it's all about judgment. And they
will have to understand it's again it's
your response to God. We talked about
this in a previous program. God is doing
A B CDE E. What are you going to do in
response to those initiatives made by
God?
>> The main reason
why
the religious world cannot understand
Daniel and Revelation is because of
something that you brought up at the
beginning of the answer of this question
and that is they misunderstand the
sanctuary.
>> Right. They focus only on one part of
the sanctuary, the altar of sacrifice.
>> Right. Yes. That's it.
>> The death of Jesus on the cross.
>> They only point to that.
>> But they don't see that the Hebrew
feasts
coordinate with the sanctuary.
>> Yes.
>> Because the Passover points to the altar
of sacrifice. Right.
>> Right.
>> First fruits to the labor, the
resurrection.
>> And then you have Pentecost, the holy
place.
>> Yam kipur, the most holy place. Correct.
So you mentioned that the sanctuary is
foundational.
>> Yeah,
>> that's the first thing that you have to
have people understand is the sequence
of the sanctuary, how it points to the
different functions of Christ in their
order.
>> And then when you get to the day of
atonement, Daniel 8:14, piece of cake.
>> Makes sense. Yes. Uh and so and so
sanctuary first and then go to Daniel
and Revelation and see how Daniel and
Revelation dovetales with the sanctuary
service.
>> And I said, I know you're coming, David.
We're going to you you're going to have
to walk your hearers through this
because there is no other Protestant
denomination that I'm aware of who
really breaks down and teaches a
sanctuary like this church. So when you
introduce them to this, you're going to
be taking them over strange ground that
they probably have not dealt with
before. So you got to walk them slowly
because it's going to be brand new
material for a lot of a lot of your
hearers.
>> Yeah. And just know I just as you were
saying um you have to ask the Holy
Spirit to lead you into reaching these
friends that are not Adventists with the
right foundation where you start this
walk of studying with them. Sometimes we
jump ahead. We want to show them what
the mark of the beast is or the judgment
is. And without really having
established a a parameter of of of study
of starting to for them to see clearly
what the scriptures teaches about
sanctuary and or then what the the
prophecies are. Uh you know it's really
hard for people to come and understand
or accept what you're saying without
really showing them from the beginning
what it what you're trying to
accomplish. So make sure that you pray
to the Lord and uh start in the right
part of your you know discussion with
them. Don't don't don't try to go to the
you know to the end when you haven't
established the beginning.
>> Yes. You know to use a baseball analogy
so many times we want to hit that grand
slam. You know you want to just knock it
out of the park. But in order to be a
grand slam you got to load the bases
first. Yeah. You know you got to put
somebody in first, second and third
>> then the grand slam. So you got to do
your homework. You can't kind of rush
into this because there's a lot of
foundation that has to be set that must
be set before you can build that
superructure upon which that foundation
sits.
>> Y
>> and pastor you have a a a study on on
you know the the chain of prophecy and I
think that's something that maybe
Francis Prince can actually get that
from our ministry and and and be able to
understand clearly from the scriptures
how to explain prophecies as well. So
there's something we have available as
well.
>> Also, I have study notes on the
sanctuary, God's way in the sanctuary,
>> right?
>> Uh where I go through all of the
sanctuary service in its order and how
it pointed forward to Christ.
>> And also I have one on the Hebrew
feasts.
The feasts give you the timing,
>> right,
>> for the events of the life of Christ
that are described in the sanctuary.
Amen. In other words, the feasts are the
calendar and the sanctuary are the
events that the calendar points to.
>> Amen.
>> And so we have study notes on both of
those.
>> And um you know, if people download the
app, they can actually uh access the
material for free.
>> The best things in life are free.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. And amen. Let's try to squeeze one
more in before our time together has
ended. This is from Roger from
Lawrenburg, Tennessee. Tennessee. Thank
you Roger for giving your name and uh
where you are writing from. I read parts
of your notes on the sanctuary.
In the notes there is a pictorial
pictorial diagram of the sanctuary on
page six. My question is do you know the
history of the sanctuary being
pictorially diagrammed?
who was the first to draw such a diagram
illustration and its history in the
second advent movement. Um the one thing
I want to add is when we go to Leviticus
and the sanctuary system, we know the
placement of the furniture. We know
what's on the north wall, the south
wall, we know the placement of the
furniture. So that's spelled out for us
in the word of God. The only other thing
that we have to add is what it looks
like. And and there's some variation as
to what it looks like. Um there's some
variation as to the sex the figure of of
Daniel too, you know, uh kind of thing.
So we don't know precisely what it looks
like, but we kind of have an idea from
the description that is given. Um and we
know precisely where they sit again from
the biblical description as to where it
is given.
>> Yeah. And we need to understand that the
sanctuary that was uh built by Moses
>> u and the temple that was built by
Solomon
um those are only replicas
>> of the real deal in heaven.
>> Yes. A shout out.
>> I mean you read about the temple that
Solomon built.
>> Yeah.
>> It has 10 layers. I mean it everything
is the scale.
>> Yes.
>> In harmony with the one in the
wilderness. But it's much greater.
>> And God is trying to show that this
heavenly sanctuary
>> this way
>> is so much greater, so much larger. It's
kind of like looking at a map.
>> You know, I can I can see California
>> in a map
>> in a little tiny map. I know exactly
where the rivers are. I know exactly
where where the cities are. I know
exactly where the roads are. I have a
view of California, but California is so
much greater. I can take a picture of
you,
>> but it's not the same as uh seeing you
in person. Right. Right.
>> Uh you know, the the heavenly sanctuary
is the original.
>> Both the tabernacle in the wilderness
and the temple that Solomon built are
only smallcale models of the heavenly to
give us enough enough information to
make it from point A to point B, from
earth to heaven. In other words,
>> amen. And in regards to this, you know,
the question, he says, who was the first
to draw such a diagram? I'm not entirely
sure. I I think there's history on that
of who was the one to first draw these
these things for this advent movement.
Uh obviously at the time of Miller,
maybe Miller himself probably started
with some of the
>> I want to say it may have been Josiah
Lich,
>> but Exactly. So there's some there's
some if individuals who helped or or put
this in in in you know illustration as
the Lord as they received information
and they put them at best of their
abilities uh and and unfortunately you
know we have no accuracy 100% accuracy
on on how
>> to write draw what not but God inspires
and gives talents to individuals and
just like a person can you know
eloquently say a sermon from the word of
God in the same way some individuals who
have skills in art can probably paint a
picture based on what they have studied
that is close to give the impression of
what the Lord wants to intend but you
know to be able to say that it's exactly
what it looked like is impossible to say
that you know as you mentioned it's just
as as as a shadow of what is to come
>> we do carry a book uh here at secrets
unsealed by Elizabeth Sarah
>> Peek the path to the throne of God
>> where she goes through all of the
details of the sanctuary and how those
details pointed forward to Christ. Uh I
would recommend anyone out there that
really is interested in knowing about
the sanctuary to get a copy of that book
from us. Um as far as a pictorial
diagram of the sanctuary, I'm stumped. I
was not able to find the first one. Um
you know what comes to mind is the 1843
chart. Yes. Prophetic chart. I think
there might be a diagram of the
sanctuary there in that chart. I'm not
sure. uh but um very early even before
the existence of the 7th adventist
church true you have diagrams of the
sanctuary surrounding the year 1844.
>> Right. Right.
>> Yeah. They were used as teaching aids.
One of the things that I realized uh in
coming here is that there is an
incredible wealth of knowledge in this
place in in over in our our uh uh
storage area, books and pamphlets and
tracks and CDs and DVDs and other kinds
of things loaded with material that we
would uh encourage you to take advantage
of. Again, our time has slipped away
from us. Thank you for joining us. We'll
see you again soon. Bye-bye and God
bless.
[Music]